learn how to use Django and the openai
API to create a chat GPT clone complete
with user authentication Tommy Taco
teaches this course he has created many
popular courses for our Channel and we
even created a course together so get
ready to improve your Django skills and
create a chat bot hey guys welcome to
this tutorial we are going to be
building an AI chatbot just like chat
GPT so we're going to use jungle and the
open AI API to build this so it's going
to be a chatbot where you can ask it
questions and it's going to give you
responses to that question so we're also
going to implement user authentication
so we're going to allow a user to
register and log into our platform and
whenever a user logs out and logs back
in they're going to see the history of
the messages that they've sent before so
I'm going to walk you through the open
AI documentation and I'm going to show
you how to use GPT 3 and gpt4 in your
application by accessing the open AI API
so you want to get the full code of
everything that we've done in this video
there will be a link in the description
below where you could get the full code
to all the files we used and the old
source code to the old project that we
built I'm Tomi a Creator at free code
Camp as well as on my own channel code
with Tommy so if you like more tutorials
like this please don't forget to check
out my Channel at codewitomi where I
make more videos on web development and
programming in general so having that
said thank you for tuning in to this
video and let's get started with this
video so the first thing that we're
going to do is to First create a Django
project so before you create a jungle
project you need to make sure that you
have Django installed so I'm going to do
pip 3 install jungle right here I'm on
my terminal on my MacBook if you're on a
Windows just open your command prompt
and type the same command but make sure
not to type three just type pip install
Django and it's going to do that for you
so I already have Django installed and
it's going to tell me that requirement
already satisfied that's because I have
Django installed but if you don't have
it installed it should go ahead and
install that for you so now the second
thing that we're going to do is to just
create a new Django project so I'm going
to be assuming that you have a basic
knowledge of Django but if you don't
have you're still okay to follow this
tutorial as I'm going to be explaining
everything I do step by step
so what I'm going to do is to go into
the folder where I want to create my
jungle project so I'm going to do CD
documents
slash projects
and I'm gonna do CD chatbots
I created a folder name chatbot
and in the
I should have a template that says pre
template so this pre-template is
basically where I store the HTML CSS
template of this project I'm going to
show you that in a bit and what I'm just
going to do is to say
mkdio means I want to make a new folder
but actually I could just create my
jungle project here I could just say
jungle iPhone admin
start project
I could call it Django chatbot
Django underscore chatbot
and then I could CD into let me just
copy this
Django chatbot
and if I press LS now I see that a new
Jungle project has been created in that
particular folder and I'm just going to
create a new Django app so I'm going to
say python3 manage.pi
start up
chatbot
now if I do LS again you can now see
that there's a new folder being created
in chatbot now that everything is done
the next thing I want to do is to open
this particular project on my vs code or
any editor or any IDE that you're using
so if you're stuck with what I did if
you don't understand what I just did so
basically when you want to create a new
project in Django you need to run a few
commands and this was what I did I first
make sure I have Django installed
because if I don't have Django installed
this is not going to work and once I
have Django installed I just seed it
into the folder where I want to create
that project so that was in my document
and I had some folder in there and then
I see it into chat bot which was the
folder and then I just created a new
Django project using this command Django
admin start project and this is the name
of the project and then I seed it into
that Django chatbot project and after
that I just checked if a project has
actually been created in that folder and
the way to check it is by doing LS if
you are on Windows and you are using
command prompt you just need to type dir
and click enter that is going to do that
for you but it shows me an error because
I'm on a MacBook and once we know that
Django project has been created what I
did was to create a new Django app in
that and I also checked to make sure the
Django app has been created which is
chatbot and that is what I did till this
point so what I'm going to do now is to
import this project I have created in my
vs code just gonna swipe so this is my
vs code right here and I'm just going to
say file open folder
and I'm gonna go into document I'm gonna
go into projects I'm gonna go into
chatbot and this is the jungle chat but
I created so this is it yeah now
whenever you're opening a new Jungle
project you need to make sure that you
open your project on the root directory
of that particular project so in The
Roots directory of your project is the
folder that contains the manage.py file
if you see money.pi in that folder that
is the right directory issue open so
this is
open and everything has been done so I'm
just going to cancel all of this to make
sure everything is good and yeah so this
is now my project folder and this is my
app folder and the first thing you want
to do to avoid any errors later is to go
into settings
in your project folder and then inside
installed apps we want to add chatbot
so I'm just going to say chatbot
now this is just to let Django know that
we've created a new app named chatbot
and that app belongs to this particular
project so this is the chatbots app
right here is an external folder but
Django doesn't really see this as an app
that is part of this project for now but
once we add it to installed apps it
knows that this chat Bots folder is part
of this whole project so that's what
that does so whenever we try to call
this chatbot folder chatbot app or
whenever I want to use any file from it
Django has access to it so that's what
that line does now that we've done that
the next thing that we're going to do is
to just create our template folder I
want to take care of everything
regarding our template first so I'm
going to create a new folder in the root
directory I'm going to name it templates
and in here I'm going to put my HTML
files and what I'm going to do is to
just come into my folder so I'm just
going to search finder
I'm just going to come into my
projects so I'm going to say projects
I'm going to come into chat bot and then
I have these two folders right here
these are the HTML files and this there
will be a link in the description below
where you can you know download this and
just use it and follow along with this
project so once you have that downloaded
just drag that into your HTML file so
for now I'm just going to copy this and
I'm going to go into
this and then the template folder that
we created right here is the same thing
as this template folder on our finder
and I'm just going to paste that in
there so now that I've pasted it if I
come in here those are right in here so
this is just the HTML template that I
already built prior to making this
tutorial so I don't want us to spend a
lot of time building out the UI so I did
this before and you can just you know
continue from this UI that I already
built the main thing I want to show you
in this video is how to build the back
end of the functionality of how this
actually works so this is the UI this is
the HTML and everything is done but the
thing is now that I have that HTML just
the way I added to the way I told Django
that this is where to access this
chatbot app I also need to tell Django
where to access HTML files because right
now this template file can this template
folder it can just be any folder it will
belong to anything it might never belong
to this project but once I tell Django
that whenever we try to take an HTML
file go into this template folder then
Django is going to know that all our
template files belong in this template
folder now for you to do that you just
need to come into settings.pi again and
you're going to come into where you see
templates is a list and you're going to
look for theirs now this there stands
for directory and it just stands for the
templates directory so where do you want
Django to look for your templates files
and I want you to look for it in this
template folder so I'm just going to say
base there
comma templates so what this is saying
is that from the base directory remember
I told you something about root
directory that's the same as the base
directory that is the folder or the
directory that contains the money.py
file so I'm saying from this particular
directory go into templates folder which
is this folder right here so now it
knows that whenever we're trying to call
or render an HTML page it's going to
have to go into this templates folder so
that is what that does now I don't
really need this number I could cancel
out this settings.pi and the next thing
I want to do is to just take care of the
URLs so I want to be able to go to my
own page and then have this my HTML show
for now if I try to run my project let's
run the project and make sure everything
is working if I say python3 manage.py
run server
this is the command that we use to run a
Django projects by the way and if you're
on a Windows once again don't type
python3 just type python money.pi run
server
so once I hit enter it says you have 18
on applied migrations we don't really
need to care about this don't worry it's
not an error it's just something we
don't need to care about for this
project now it says where our project is
running on this particular Port now
let's just open it so we could click on
open
command and click so as you can see
everything is working it says that the
install Works successfully
congratulations that means this project
is good there's nothing wrong with it
but the only thing wrong with it for us
is that it's showing me this Django
template when I come into my home URL or
when I come into my website I don't want
to be seeing this I want to see the HTML
templates that I built so we're going to
take care of that now and the first
thing we need to do is to go into chat
Bots we can just close this and in
chatbot we're going to create a new file
named urls.pi
so let's rename that as there was an
error
so we're just going to say urls
so what this does is that every single
URL in our project we're going to
configure it in here so for example
let's say this is my project and I want
to have something like slash login I'm
going to come into URLs and say there is
a URL name login in my project or if I
just don't have a normal home page which
is just this number on page I also have
to configure it here now let's do that
the first thing that we need to do is to
just say from Django the URLs import
path so this path is something that
Django gave us that allows us to
basically specify each URL as a path and
I'm going to show you how to do that so
you're going to have to create a new
list called URL patterns
equals to list and then we're going to
use this part that we imported so we're
going to see Parts we're specifying a
new URL as a path and then I'm just
going to have this yeah I'm going to
explain what this does and I'm going to
take from views Dot
chat but I'm also going to explain what
all of this does and I'm going to say
name equals chatbot
okay so now what this does is that
when I say path it takes three different
arguments like this and the first
argument is to specify what path I'm
trying to create so this stands for the
home page that means whenever a user
comes into my own page let's say when I
deploy this website to the web and I
host it on something like
www.chatbot.com right
so this is my home page and that's what
this specifies if I do something like
slash login then this
path means www.chatbot.com login right
so I hope you understand what that means
now and since we know what that is so
this specifies the home page the next
thing is that what it's saying is
whenever a user go to this home page we
want to render this chat about the view
from the views.py now there's a file
named views.pi as you can see in here
and this file so I'm just going to
enlarge this a little bit and this file
what it does is that it allows us to
create functionalities for every single
URL page so what we're saying is
whenever a user come into this home page
what do we want to do do we want to
render an HTML page do we want to
register something in the database
everything is going to be done in this
views.pi so now what we need to do is to
create a new function
named chatbot it's going to take a
request
and then for now we're going to pass
we're going to come back to this but
what I just did here is to create a new
function named chatbot so that when
we're trying to call views the chat but
it doesn't give us an error so as you
can see it gives us this error for now
that's because we don't have views
imported so we just need to do from dot
import views
so that is done so we've imported
views.chat bot no error because it knows
that there's a chatbot function in here
just going to collapse this and once we
have that we're giving it name of
chatbot so we're just naming this URL
chatbot that's just what we're doing for
that now I'm going to save this and for
now I'm passing and since we know what
we've done
we can basically come back here now and
remove this pass and what I want to do
when a user comes into this chatbot is
to render this chatbot.html page so
instead of showing this you know default
Django template I just want to show my
own HTML page to do this I'm going to
say return
render
and I'm going to say request
I'm trying to request the chatbot
.html now because Django already knows
where to get our template files whenever
we're requesting for one because we
specify that in the settings remember
now it knows that it's going to come
into templates folder and it's going to
look for chatbot.html which is this and
it's going to render that
now if I come in here and eat refresh
you should expect that to work right but
no it still shows this now this is just
because we did all of this for our
Django app but remember this app is just
a subset of the main project so this is
the main project folder what we need to
do is to come into the URLs of the
project folder and then we also need to
tell these URLs that this jungle this
project URLs where to go whenever a user
comes into the home page we told the app
but we didn't tell the URL so for us to
do this we need to do something called
include
so we are importing include and what
this does is that it basically allows us
to include a URL kind of copy a URL from
an app so this is what we're doing when
I say path
and I'm going to do the same thing
I'm just going to say include
chatbot dot URLs so what this is doing
is that whenever a user tries to go to
the home page it's going to go into
chatbot which is this app it's going to
go into the URLs file which is this URLs
it's going to look for a particular URL
that match this and this is this URL and
whatever is being done here is what it's
going to do right here so that's
basically what that does now we can save
this we can actually close this now when
we come here and refresh it works so as
you can see it gives us this basic thing
I I am your chat but you can ask me
anything good if I do I
nothing happens for now but we're going
to take care of that in a bit so now
that we know we have all of that done
the next thing that we want to do is
like when we create when we say
something like Hi how are you doing
we type something in there and we hit
enter or we eat send we want that
message to show here and we obviously
want to have a response also so I'm
going to tell you how to do that now and
to do this we're going to use a little
bit of JavaScript so I'm going to walk
you through all these steps don't worry
now we're going to come into our
templates let me just explain what this
template file does so the first thing it
does is to extend from this base.html if
you know Django you know there's
something in extend and I'm going to go
through it quickly so this is a
base.html file this sounds like the
backbone or the Bedrock of our template
file so this has all these Constructors
every single thing that HTML files need
and what it just does is allows other
files to extend from it so what it does
is that wherever we have this thing
called block content any file that
extends from it could basically add
their own code in this block content
right and it's going to have the same
code as all of this but with unique code
in this block content so if I come into
chatbot you see it's extending from
base.html that means if I remove all of
this every single thing from the O file
right so let me say I remove this block
content every single thing right here it
basically let me remove this also it
basically has the same file as base.html
the same thing no no difference but now
if I add
just going to add everything back if I
add this block content which is this
right it's going to be the same file as
it's based.html but any code I put into
this block content is going to be
inserted into this block content right
here so that means so as you can see
this blog content is in the body tag
that means this chatbot all of this code
is going to be in the body tag of this
base.html I hope that makes sense so now
this is a new file that extends from the
base.html kind of copies and pastes but
what this allows us to do instead of
having to write all of this code again
for every single file and that's going
to be time consuming it just allows us
to extend from it and only make changes
to where we need to make changes which
is just the body of the page and that is
what we did here
so now that we have that as you can see
this is the body of the page this is
just a basic form right here it has a
csrf token and in Django this stands for
cross-site request forgery and it's kind
of like an attack that it prevents an
attack so cross side requests produce an
attack but in this token kind of
verifies that anyone that's trying to
access this data is authorized to access
that data so that's what that does and
you have to put it there whenever you
submitting a form in Django even though
it's going to throw you an error so this
is just the basic this UI that you see
right here that is what that does
nothing spectacular about that
and this is just styling it this is just
a basic CSS page to study once again
there's a link in the description below
where you can access this template file
and follow me along so now that we have
this we could close this base.html
because we don't need it and right now
if I type I it just puts some random
stuff in the URL and it doesn't really
show anything and as you can see when I
type I the page start refreshing and
reloading we don't want that we want
something generic like when I say I it
automatically comes up here and gives me
a response that is what we want so we're
going to do that right now to do this we
need JavaScript so at the end of this
div tag of the body we're going to
create script
and let's just end the script
right here
so now that is what we need to do and
then the first thing that we need to do
in here we're going to first
actually have three different constants
so I'm going to paste the code and
explain what this does
so just to save time I'm going to paste
the code rather than type in everything
line by line so now what this does is
that it's selects a particular query so
what it does is it comes into message
list cool so I'm going to come in here
and we're going to look for where we see
message lists
so in your days we're just going to save
messages
copy that let's search for it
so as you can see there's a list right
here named message list and what this
does this JavaScript does it just
selects that particular query or that
particular tag so now all this Old Tag
this list tag
it has it stored in this constantly
messages list it does the same for
message form now a research message form
we don't need to search that because we
have that right here we can see form
class message form it basically has
access to this old form and stores that
access in this message form so we can
manipulate anything or do anything we
want to do with that form because we now
have installed as a variable as a
constant and the input it does the same
thing so the input is basically this
input bar right here and as you can see
input text and that's a class of message
input and it stores that also in a
constant name message input and now the
next thing we want to do is to create
a new event listener so when a user
clicks on submit or enter or send we
want to create an events list listener
that does something so when this submit
button is clicked we want to do some
stuff first to do this I'm just going to
also copy and paste some code in here
I'm just going to paste this in here so
as you can see we're creating a message
form
dot add event listener so now that we
have access to that message form we are
adding an event listener so that means
whenever something is done to this form
this message form once again this
message form is this
tag and basically this form so what
we're saying is from this form when the
submit button is clicked that means this
button right here is clicked then we
want to do some stuff first of all we
say invent dot prevent default which
means once the submit button is clicked
we don't want the page to refresh that
is what that does and then what we're
going to do is to then store the message
that was inputted so what we're saying
is
constant we're creating a new message
constant and then we're sending message
input.value.ream so what the user puts
in here we just want to get it but trim
it down right to only the words that you
get so let's say it has a lot of spaces
and all of that once remove all of that
and just trim it down to the sentence
and what we're saying is if message your
length is zero then we want to return
nothing so that means if the user
doesn't type anything in here and just
clicks on enter or send we don't want to
return anything because they didn't send
an actual message now that is what that
does right and then the next thing we
want to do is to kind of create a list
so when a user sends a message right
here
so I'm just gonna paste this code right
here now once the user sends a message
since we already know that once this
submit button is clicked all of this is
being done so after we check that and
make sure that it's not
zero that means the message is not blank
then we want to create an input
we're going to create a new basically a
new variable right and then we're
creating a new element called list now
I'm going to tell you what we're trying
to do here what we're trying to do is
that once a user clicks on
send we want to basically show the user
the message right here like this is the
message you sent right kind of like in
any chatbot or any chat system it's
going to show your message and the
person you're chatting with that's what
we want to do so once the user clicks on
a and it clicks enter we want to pop the
message up here saying you sent a right
that is what we're doing right here and
what we're doing is we're creating a new
message item and we're creating a list
so we're basically trying to duplicate
or replicate what is being done in here
right we want to make something look
like this
so that's what we're doing in JavaScript
so we're saying if we come down here
we're saying
create a new list element and then in
that list element we want to add a class
add a message name sent so what we're
doing is basically what they did here so
in that list
right we're seeing at the class message
and sent this is message and received
but we're going to kind of create a new
class so what it's doing is that
whenever user click submit it's
basically replicating this and just
creating a new list adding a class that
says message and sent that is basically
what it is doing right here so we get a
new message item which is a list and
then in that list we add a class
message and sent
done and now the next thing we want to
do is inside that list just the way you
can see that inside this list there is
now a few code in here that says AI chat
bots so this is sent by the AI chatbot
and the message at the AI chatbot sent
that is what we're doing here also we
are saying this is sent by you and then
we are getting the message that you sent
and just kind of pasting it there so
what we're now doing is in messagelist
dot append child message item so since
we have message list which is basically
this message list right here this UL
what we're going to say is under this
URL when we want to append a child and
that child should be message item and
that message item is a new list we
created which has all of the information
of the message you sent so it's
basically going to append a new child
kind of like pasting a new list in here
that is what that does and what it then
does after appending that is making the
value of this blank so whenever I say I
and I hit enter I don't want the eye to
still be here I want this to be gone
once I hit enter so that is what that
does that that says message dot value
right now the next thing I want to do
I'm going to paste another bunch of code
in here but I'm going to explain what
this does line by line
we're just going to paste this in here
and now since we have the message that
the user sent we're going to send a
request to our backend so in this views
we're going to kind of send a request in
here so what we're doing is we're going
to send the message that the user
inputs and sent we're going to send it
to this back end and from these views we
are going to now create a function that
sends that message to open AI API and
then gives us the response and then
we're going to show that response right
here so let me explain what this does
also there's something in JavaScript
called Fetch so we can kind of use this
fetch to send a request to like an API
or to like you know your backend in this
case uh jungle backend and that's what
we're doing so we're saying Fetch and
the method is post so the method of this
particular fetch is both of this
particular request and we're just giving
it the address which is what you need to
do for this to work and then we're
giving it the kind of like the
parameters we need to give it for it to
you know give us a response so we're
giving it a body csrf middleware token
remember when we said we added this
which is kind of like preventing an
attack so we need to also send that
token so everything goes well
that's what we're doing right here once
again the code to the template is going
to be in the description and the code to
the whole everything we're going to do
in this video the full project is also
going to be in the description below so
you can check that out if you're stuck
anywhere if you need to copy and paste
the code you can check everything out in
the description below
and then there's also a message
that we sent into this particular
backend and that message is basically
the message that the user inputs right
which is this right here if we come here
we created a new
message right here
which is message input.trim good now
that we're sending all of these where
are we sending it to you we're sending
it to this home page where is this home
page if we come into URLs this is where
we're sending it to and then it's going
to go into views the chatbot which is
this function so that means in here
we're going to receive whatever we are
sending all these parameters which is
the message then we're going to send
that message to opens AI API so let's do
that now that all of this is done what
we're going to do is
we're going to get a response so I'm
going to show you
oh I'm going to explain all of this how
this gets the response in a bit but
before I come back to this we're going
to have to first create a response in
here and I'm going to show you how it
works or because we'll just talk about
it now so what this does is just once we
get a response which is like when we say
when we get the message and then we say
return response right return response or
something so I'm just typing rubbish now
but you get the point of what I'm saying
so when we say return response that
response is going to be stored in this
response variable and then we can get
that data right so that is going to
return that response as a Json response
and then we're going to say response
because response.json convert it to a
Json type that JavaScript can understand
and then it's going to say it's going to
create a new variable name response and
it's going to say data the response
which is basically the data that we sent
back from this from our right here and
then what it does is that it basically
does the same thing that we did in here
which is creating a new message so that
I can pop up up here and that's exactly
the same thing it did and he also
appended it to message item now enough
talking now let's get straight to the
coding now that I explained what all
this JavaScript does let's actually come
in here and you know undo it from this
part so now the first thing I want to do
is I want to first get if
the request the method being used to
request for this page
so I'm going to say request. method if
done method is post
then I want to do something so I'm going
to do something now let me explain
something quickly if let's say when we
come to this URL directly I will just go
to 127 right here the method being used
to request for this URL or this page is
a get method originally or initially but
whenever we're trying to send a message
just like we did here you can now see
that
this page has been accessed if I come
into fetch it's been accessed with a
method of posts so that's how I can
distinguish from when a message is being
sent to this page and when this page is
just being loaded normally so if a
message is being sent and we do
something like this and we hit enter
that is a post method so that's when
Django knows that okay I'm I have to
receive a message and provide a response
but if the method being used is just a
get method then he knows I don't really
need to give a response or get anything
I just need to render this HTML page
right so I hope you understand that and
that's what that does and we're just
going to come into views.pi and so we're
saying if request the method dispose now
we want to do some stuff I'm just going
to say message
so I want to get the message that was
being sent in here I'm going to say
request dot post dot get
and what we need to get in here is in
the body that was sent into this
our URL we need to get the variable that
was used to send which is message and
they were going to come in here and
paste message now we have the message
that the user typed in here and what
we're going to do is to now provide a
response
now the response for now let's just say
hi this is my response
so I'm going the response we're going to
use actually is the response from open
AI but for now let's just say this just
to make sure everything is working
before we actually Implement open AI API
so now we specify this response and what
I'm going to do is to return this
response as a Json response I'm going to
say return Json response
so what I'm doing is to return this
response as Json response but for me to
be able to use Json response I need to
import Json response from Django so I'm
going to say Django from django.http
import
just make sure when putting it right
import Json
response so now that's going to allow me
to import Json response allow me to use
Json response so now that I have that
what I'm just going to do is to import
return this I'm gonna have my normal
brackets and in there I'm going to have
the curly braces and I want to report
return
the message
you don't really need to return the
message but let's just return it also to
make sure we have this message in the
HTML and then the main thing to return
is the response
so I want to return the response
as a variable name response
good so now this works now everything
should actually work perfectly now let's
test here if I come in here now I hit
refresh and I say
a
you can see that it shows me a and then
it gives me a response saying I this is
my response everything is working now
we're able to actually send a message
from our HTML and send it to our backend
using JavaScript Fetch and then we're
able to get do some processing in the
back end send a response back and get
that response we've basically done most
of the heavy work now the only thing we
just need to do is to get into open Ai
and then get the API key and from that
API key we need to paste we need to use
that API key to basically access opens
AI you know machine learning API that
allows us to use a chatbot I'm going to
show you how to do this now now the
first thing we need to do
is to first make sure we have open AI
installed so I'm going to come open this
up
and what I'm going to do is to open up a
new
or actually in here in my terminal I'm
just going to say
I'm going to clear this out to make sure
everything is clean I'm going to say P3
install open AI
it's gonna say requirement already
satisfied for me because I have it
installed but for you it should go ahead
and install that
now what this does the basic thing that
it does is just allows us to use open AI
in Python now before you even use any of
this you need to make sure you have an
open AI account created so you need to
go to openai.com and create an account
and once you have an account created you
need to create an API key so you need to
go to your account and down here under
user you're going to see API Keys now
you need to make sure you have an API
key I'm just going to create a new API
key to show you how this is done so I'm
going to create a new secret key and I
could just say
Django
chatbots
and you're going to create a new key I'm
going to copy that key and it's done now
this will allow us to use this
open AI API to be able to create a
chatbot now I'm going to come back in my
code and what I'm going to do is just
create a new variable that says open AI
API key
I'm gonna paste that in there so now
just to make sure I have that stored I
have pasted that in there and the next
thing I'm going to do is just to come
into open AI actual API and I'm going to
show you how this works I'm going to go
into documentation to show you
everything about your API and you know
what it does so for this we're going to
be using the chat completion model and
what this does it just allows us to be
able to send a message and then kind of
receive a response but they call it chat
completion which is uh the name for this
system so that's what it does that you
can read through this and understand how
everything works but I'm going to just
explain to you how everything works in
you know in the code so this is kind of
like a basic system you could open going
to their playground and play around with
the API and see everything you can do
with it and you know there are a lot of
other things you could do not just chat
you could generate image you know
there's um codex API which is kind of
like an API just set for helping you to
code and there are various apis that
open AI offer but for this one as I said
we're going to be using the text
completion so I'm going to quit this and
since we have our API key I'm just going
to come back into my code so now that we
know we have that the next thing we need
to do is to kind of create a function
that sends
a request to open AI API and sends it
our message and then we want to get a
response from that API so I'm going to
do Dev and I'm going to say ask
open AI
and in here I'm gonna pass it a message
so we need the message as a parameter so
we could send that to open AI and now we
want to get a response from open Ai and
to be able to get this response we just
create a new variable and we're going to
say open AI
the completion
dot create so automatically we can see
that we have this error this is because
we know we have open air installed but
we didn't import it so we need to import
open AI to be able to use it in our code
so we've imported open here and that is
gone and after specifying the open AI
API key what we need to do is to say
open AI dot API key
is equals to open AI API key so this
kind of registers that that this is our
API key this just stores the API key as
a variable but this sends that API key
to open AI so now that we've done that
we can come back to our function and
what we can just do is to say the
completion.create and I want to say the
model I want to use so the model I want
to use
you know
so we could just do this equals
how many is the text
davichi
003 so there are various modules as I
said you could go into the API
documentation and and their playground
and check around with various models and
everything you want to use and the
prompt
The Prompt is basically the message that
the user sent
and the max tokens we're just going to
set to Max tokens for it
let's say something like 150
and n equals one you're going to set
that as a parameter also you need all of
this when you're sending a request you
can also go to the API documentation and
you could know how to like change all of
this to whatever value you want
depending on you know your the cost of
the API that you're planning to use so
we can say stop let's just say that as
none so it doesn't stop for any reason
and then
temperature
equals 0.7
so these are the parameters you need to
specify to be able to send this or to be
able to get a response and now we can
we're going to say answer
which is a response equals to response
dot choice
this is how we get the actual text
response I want to get the first one
right
and you want to say dot text Dot strip
this so now if I don't do all of this
I'm going to show you what this does so
I'm just before doing all of this I'm
going to print
response
I'm Gonna Save this I'm just gonna drag
up my terminal and now whenever
actually what we need to First do is to
use this as the response so I'm going to
say response call
ask open Ai and send it this message so
instead of just sending us blank
response saying hi this is my response I
want to send this particular message to
open ask open AI which is going to get a
response and we're going to have to
return answer
but before we return this answer I want
to just show you what this response is
on its own so let's just
run that I'm going to come in here hit
refresh I'll say how are you doing
and when I say that you can see because
I printed the response you can see the
kind of response it gives us it gives us
choices you know it gives us all of this
it gives us all of this these are the
text this is the main response that
we're looking for so you can see we
asked how it's doing how are you doing
he gave us no for now because we didn't
actually return anything in that
um if I come down here I'm just gonna
come down so in here we didn't return
anything so that's why it gave us no but
we're going to fix that in a second
so now as you can see what it does is
that for choices
it gives us text which is the actual
response we don't really need all of
this to show to the user this just gives
us information about the usage like the
amount of tokens we used and the model
and all of that but what we want to show
to the user is this text so this text is
what we want to show to the user and if
you come in here that is what we did we
said response.choice so the response I
wanted to choice and from the choice
what we did this should actually be
choices because those choices right
there and then we got the first value
and that first value is basically this
list right here right and they were
saying from this sorry this dictionary I
was saying from this dictionary we want
to get text so we said text and then we
did the strip so what the strip does is
that it removes all of this you know
formatting and just gives us in a normal
text so that is what that does I hope
you understood that and then we're just
going to equip this back and instead of
printing response we're going to remove
this we're going to have our answer and
then we're going to return our answer so
so now everything should work perfectly
so if I kind of just going to refresh
this page I'm going to say Hi how are
you doing
today
now let's wait you can see now he says
I'm doing well thank you how about you I
could answer that but what I'm just
going to do is to test it out and see if
this actually works fine so I'm gonna
say who is Bill Gates
now let's see what it says
so let's give it a second it says Bill
gate is an American businessman gate
software developer inventor and
philanthropist basically gives us all of
the details of Bill Gates so let's say
what is free code camp
let's see if he knows everything
I'll give you a second so it says
frequent Camp is an open source online
platform designed to teach coding skills
to everyone so this is basically a fully
functional chatbot that you know you can
ask a question and it will give you a
response this is very good this was the
point of this video this is what we want
to do in this video now I hope you
understood everything we've done out to
this point because for now we've been
able to actually send a message and then
get a response so we could say something
like who are you
and let's see it says I am a human being
just like you kind of funny because it's
an AI but that gave us an answer which
is what we want so we've been able to do
that in this video now that we've been
able to view this chat but let's take it
to the next level so what we want to do
now is to allow users to log in and sign
up and so we want to save chat to like a
database so that when I log in and I ask
a couple of questions I want to be able
to log out and when I log in another
time or another on another device I want
to still have access to my chat history
so we're going to do this so first to do
this what we need to do is to allow
users to log in and sign up and then we
need to create a chat database so
whenever we make a user send a message
and we make a request to open AI API we
want to save the message and the
response into our chat database so let's
do that
now the first thing we need to do is to
actually create a login and register
page so once again all this template
file is going to be available in the
description below and you're going to be
able to use that easily once you get
them from the link in the description
and what we're just going to do is to
come into templates right here and we're
going to create login
.html
and then also we have the HD login code
and we're just gonna
put it in here and then that's just a
basic login page with the styling and
everything and then we're going to do
the same for register so we're going to
create a register
dot HTML and then in here also what we
need to do is just to paste the register
code but you're going to have this
already so you don't need to paste
anything so now this is just the basic
code for the register page now we need
to make sure that this has a URL so what
I'm going to do is to go into urls.pi
I'm going to set login
I'm going to set register
and I'm going to do one more I'm going
to set
the logout
I'm just going to copy this paste paste
all of this here
you need to make sure we have come out
in here so we don't get an error you
just put command everything now we save
that so we need to create this login
register and logout function so we're
going to have to come into views.pi and
we could close all of this for now and
then actually before we close that let's
create a new one
so we could close these two and then we
could create a login
you could take a request
and for now we can just say return
render
request
login.html
now we're going to do the same
for logout for register I mean
now we're just going to say
register.html
and then for logout we're just going to
Def log out
I'm going to take a request
and now we just need this to do alt the
logout
request
so this just allows us to log out a user
but first to use this odd we actually
need to import or up here in our
views.py file and for us to import alt
so hot is kind of like an authentication
library that Django provides for us as
default so first to import alt we're
just going to do from django.comtrib
import Earth
now that is going to work but we don't
need to worry about that for now let's
just make sure that the login and
register page are even loading up so I'm
going to go back in here and I'm gonna
go to slash login
so as you can see we have this login
page let's go to slash register
you can see we have this register page
so we want that whenever a user put in
these details and click on register we
want to register them and log them in
automatically so let's do that now the
first thing we need to do is to come
into views right here in our register
page let's actually close that bar and
then right here in our register view we
just need to do a couple of things so
first of all if I come back in here in
my register page you can see that we
have a basic form
if I show you right here we have this
form with a method of post and it has
username email password and confirm
password and once they click on register
it submit that form to this page right
here
so when they click on register I want to
get that all the details of everything
they clicked on and submit it in my
database so for me to do this just the
way I used ifrequest.com in if request
dot Methodist Post in here I'm going to
do exactly the same thing so I know when
a form is being submitted to this page
so I'm going to say if request
the method
is equals to post
and what I'm just going to do is to say
username I'm going to get the username
not that we need the username
because you request
the post
username
so let's just make sure that your
so we're gonna have to do the same thing
for the email
request
the post you can just do email
same thing for the passwords also so
password one
is equals to request dot post
and then for password two we could just
copy that and change one into two
so let me show you what this is doing is
getting from this form this register
form is getting the values that the user
input using the name so the name of
username is username that's why we're
getting a using username we're starting
it in a variable name username email is
email the first person this password one
the second password is password too and
as you can see that's exactly what we're
doing right here so now that we have
that the first thing we want to do is to
error check so we want to First make
sure that the user inputted passwords
that are similar that are identical that
are the same not just similar so I want
to make sure that password one if
password one
let's go to password too so we want to
make sure that password one is equal to
password two
so only if that is true then we'll
continue so let's just say pass for now
we'll do some stuff else if the
passwords are not same so we'll just
send an error for now we just send error
message
let's just say errone ask a message I
will say error message is equals to
something like password
don't match
so that's our error message and then
when this happens what we want to do is
to render this page again but this time
around with an error message so say
return render
request
register.html
but this time around you are sending an
error message so say error message
and then say error message
so that that should work and what we can
just do is we could try to test this out
so if we come in here and hit refresh
and let's say I do
let me just do some random things
and if I do this and this they don't so
as you can see it tells us that password
don't match
so because the password does not match
it just brings us back to this page
telling us that it doesn't match and
that is working successfully but now
what if the password match we want to
then continue with creating this user so
the next thing we want to do is to just
create this user so say try I'm going to
use like a try accept in here let's say
try let's pass for now
and then we'll say accept
and let's also pass for now so in try we
want to try to create a new user so
we're going to say user equals now
before we do anything we want to make
sure that we have the user model
imported so I'm just gonna say from
Django
.com trip
dot Earth dot models
import user
so this basically allows me to access
Django user model which is like the
module of the table that Django creates
for us to be able to store or create
users on our platform
so what I'm just going to do is to say
user and I want to create a new user so
for me to create a news I'm going to say
user.objects so from the user module dot
objects
dot create user so this is where I used
to create a new user and I want to
create a new user using the username
the email
and the password so let's just pick one
password anyone is fine as long as they
are the same
so once that is done I'm just going to
save that user by saying user.safe
so these are the save save that user in
our database and once the user has been
created and saved I want to log the user
in automatically so I'm just going to
say alt the login
request
user so I'm trying to log this user in
right here
and then I'm gonna say return
redirect so after logging the user in I
want to take them back to the you know
chatbot so I'm going to say
chatbots
this redirects me to the chatbot now
first to use this redirect we need to
import redirect right here so I'm going
to say redirect and that allows us to
use redirect in here so now if none of
this works like if it doesn't create a
user successfully the next thing I want
to do is to pass an error saying
something like error creating and the
account so I'm going to say error
message
because to let's say error creating
account
and again just like I did here I want to
return
this page with an error message
good so now that should work
successfully and everything should be
fine right now what we just need to do
is to test this out so you I've saved it
if I come back in here now and I try to
say when I first refresh okay let me
just refresh with this and I say tell me
and I say
att.co and let me give you the password
that match
and I say register it says error
creating an account right so that means
there's an error somewhere so what we
need to do is to come up here and see if
they gave us any error here okay they
didn't give us any error here but I just
noticed something so we haven't applied
migrations in Django what you need to do
is to apply migration this is kind of
like saving all these models that they
gave us the user models and everything
we want to save it into our database if
we don't save it to our database there's
no way we can create like data in or
save data in our database so first need
to have a database before we can save
data in that database first to do that
we just come here cut out of this server
we're just going to say python3
manage.pi run server nope money.pi
migrate
so once that is done and we run the
server again everything should be
working successfully so now if I try to
submit that form and hit enter you can
now see that it logs me in it says AI
chat but I am I am your AI chat but you
can ask me anything so what I want to do
is write yeah I want to be like I then I
want to have the username so I want you
to be customized for this specific user
I'm going to come back in my code where
I have chat bot and right in yeah I
could say I and then I could just put
the user that is logged in by saying
user.username so it's going to get the
currently logged in user and tell me the
username now if I hit refresh in here
you can see now it says I told me I am
your AI chatbot you can ask me anything
so this is basically what I wanted to do
now the next thing once we know that
this is working is to now allow a user
to login from the login page so we're
going to come back to views just the way
we did for register we want to allow a
user to log into so this is quite
similar but also very shorter so the
same thing we did by getting if the
request was the request method was post
we're going to do it again so I'm going
to say if request
dot method
is equals to post
we're going to say username
equals to request
dot posts so we're going to get that
username and say username
and then we also want to get the
password
because the request the post
so as you can see username and password
done so if I come into login you can see
that in this form that we created we
have a username name and then we have a
password name for the username and
password input Fields so that's how we
are getting the value that the user
input and once we have that what we need
to do is to try to authenticate that
user so we can say user equals author on
30k and what this is doing is kind of
checking if this user actually exists
before we even try to like log the user
in so we're going to say request
username
equals to the username that we collected
and then password
is equals to the password that we
collected
so this just checks and then what we can
now do is to kind of say in here we can
just say if user is not none so we are
making sure that the user is not an
invalid user so if this user is in my
database I want to say Alt
the login so I'm kind of logging the
user in I'm going to say request
and I want to log this user in
and then after logging the user in I
want to redirect them to the home page
so return redirect chatbot
else
so the else means that if this user
does not exist so that's what this else
is for so we're going to say else
then we want to say an error message
something like invalid user
so we're going to say error underscore
message
invalid we can say invalid username
or password
and then we could just return
render
so I want to return and render the
normal HTML template
so we could say request
and then we want to render the
login.html
and then we're just going to say error
message
and an error message
so this is what we want and everything
should be working perfectly so what
we're going to do is all of this should
be working but we can say else that
means if the request or method is not
post then we could add an else statement
saying we just want to render this
normally
so what this is doing is if you create
the method disposed then we go ahead and
lock the user in but if it's not posed
then we just want to show the user
deform
now once we've done this we could go
ahead and test to see and make sure that
this is working successfully
so we could save this and actually what
I'm going to do is to first go to slash
logout
so it says views.logger didn't return an
HTTP response it returned none instead
so what we can do is under logout after
logging the user out which can just
redirect them
to the login page so they can log in
so now if you try to log out again
it takes me to the login page now let me
log in with what I created and say login
good now it says I told me I am your
chatbot you can ask me anything
another thing I want to do is to have
login and register here but if the user
is logged in I want to say logout
instead and then I could say something
like welcome told me the username so
let's do that real quick so in here in
the chatbot what we could just do we
could basically even have
so I could come here in the chat but so
right here where we say chat it is right
here
okay basically I have another one and I
could say something like login so first
of all I could have an a tag
that says
goes to login
and I could say login
and I could just copy that leave some
space
do the same thing for register
so I only want to do this if the user is
not authenticated so what I'm going to
do is to say I'm going to use like a
ginger template style and this allows me
to use like conditional statements in
HTML so I'm going to say if user dot is
underscore authenticated
so if user is authenticated then I'm
going to show them to just log out or
else
I want to show them to login and
register or register so I'm going to say
this and I'm gonna say end if
so now if the user is logged in
it shouldn't show us nothing it doesn't
show us anything under
but if we log out
right and then let's say we go to the
home page so it should show us login and
register as you can see here it does we
just can't see it because the background
is blue and the text is blue so we could
come here and change that so we could
say something like Style
color
so because of color
and then we could say yellow
let's see
so as you can see it works let's do
exactly the same thing here we could
just say Style
color
yellow
and let's see if that works too good so
now it says login or register now I
could come to login login and you see I
don't see login or register again
now what I can just do instead of scene
login or register I want to see welcome
to me and then after that I want to see
logout
so what I'm just gonna do is right here
instead of this I'm going to copy this
particular code I'm going to paste it in
here
and then instead of saying login or log
out login or register I'm gonna say
I'm gonna have like a b tag
that says welcome and honestly the
user's user I'm going to say user dot
username so whoever is logged in it's
going to tell the user welcome and yeah
I want to tell user to log out if they
want to
so I'm going to say logout
so this should work now so as you can
see it says welcome to me and it gives
me the option to log out and I could log
in back again it tells me well come tell
me this is perfect and this is basically
what I want so now that all of this is
done we could now go straight to being
able to save this user's database I mean
this user's message into our database so
let's do that right now I'm just going
to come into my models.pi file and in
here I'm going to create a new model for
us so what I'm going to create is a
model named chat so I'm going to say
class chat and it's going to take from
models
dot model
so now what I'm going to now do is to
have four different fields one is going
to be the user the other one is going to
be the message
the other one is going to be the
response
that the AI gives us and the last one is
going to be the date and time it was
created at so we'll know how to arrange
the particular the data or messages so
now we can see models the foreign key we
can use the foreign key to link to the
user on the user database so we're going
to say user but we didn't import user
here so we're just going to say from
Django dot country
dot Earth dot models then we can import
the user model
so now that we can do that we can now
use the user as a foreign key and when
you use foreign keyword you say on
delete and they will say models dot
Cascade
now for the model we're just gonna for
the message we're just going to say
models.txt field because it's just a
normal text field
we're going to say the same for the
response so models.txt field
so because it could be a lot of text and
then for the created art what we need to
do is to just say models dot daytime
field
and then we want to say Auto now
equals true
so that should work and instead of it
just having not having a name we want
every single data to have a specific
name so we can use a method and
we're just going to have the underscore
this is string
let's give itself
and then let's return for the name
um let's see let's say
self
Dutch user.username so I want to get the
username of the user that you know sent
the message and then let's say we want
to say the message that the user sent to
save the message
so this should work and now whenever we
make any change to these models.py file
we need to migrate that change into our
database so I'm going to scroll this up
I'm going to do Ctrl C the first thing
we need to do is to do Python 3 manage
dot Pi make migrations
so that kind of saved the changes but
then what we need to do is to now
migrate that changes so money.pi
migrate if I migrate you can see that it
told me I created a new model named chat
which is what I did now let me migrate
that change into my database good so now
in my database I have a new data name a
new data table name chat so now I just
want to run my server again
and that should be working but I want to
see that I have created these models
named chat I want to verify it so there
are two ways I could basically come here
and then just open my db.sqlite because
that is my table and if I drag this you
can see it says chatbot chat so under
the chatbot app a table name chat has
been created if I click on that you see
it has everything we did the ID message
response created at and the user name of
the the user ID of the user that created
this but we don't want to do this this
is kind of like old fashion so what
we're going to do is to use the Django
admin that it's provided for us so if I
come here
where I come to
want to slash admin
you're gonna see that
there is like this admin page that
Django creates for us and what I want to
do is to create an admin user so right
here you can see that um first of all
I'm logged in as told me but right here
it tells me that the user I'm logged in
as is not an admin so it's not
authorized to access this admin page so
first to create an admin page you need
to run a particular command again so
we're going to do Python 3
manage.pi create
super user
so we can say admin
you can leave this blank and say admin
admin yup and then we've created a new
admin user and now let's
run server
so now we could try to log in with that
admin user that we created
let's say admin login good so now this
is kind of how we can see like our
database or all the users we have in our
in our platform so you can see we have
to use as one named admin and one named
Tomi that we created earlier so the the
other thing I want to do is to verify
that I actually have this chat saved in
my database too as you can see it
doesn't show here but it shows in the
sqlite file that we checked earlier so
for us to make it show here we need to
kind of register it on that admin page
to do this we're going to use the
admin.pi file so first of all we need to
say from dot models
import chart so the first one import
chat and then we're going to say admin
Dot site dot register
I want to register chat
so now if you come back in here and hit
refresh you can now see that we have
chat as a database saved here so that
table works so now that we know we have
a database table name chat what we can
do is that we're going to come back into
these views and we don't really need all
of this for now but whenever a user
sends a message right so in here
whenever user types in a message we want
to save that message and the response of
the AI in this chat database so that
whenever a user wants to check his
history they can easily check their
history so if I refresh this page this
should change to admin and you can see
change to admin because now I am logged
in as the admin user on this platform so
that is also good now the thing we need
to do is to make sure we are saving and
registering all the messages into our
chat model or into our chat database so
let's do that right now
the first thing we need to do is to just
go back into India so I'm just going to
come back in
yeah this is actually quite easy first
of all I need to make sure I'm importing
chat so I'm going to say from those
models import chat
now that I know chat is being imported
so from chatbot what I'm just going to
do is to say
after getting the message and the
response before returning the response
I'm going to kind of
like save that message and response in
our chat database so I'm going to say
chat equals chat
and all we're going to do is say user so
we want to see the user in here all
right by sending this message and we
want it to be the currently logged in
user so the user that is currently
logged in so say user equals request
dot user so this is how you get the user
that is currently logged in by using
request.user and message equals so we're
saying this message which is this
message right here we are saying is
equals to the message that the user sent
we're just going to copy that
am I going to do exactly the same thing
too for the response so we're going to
say this response right here
just gonna come in here and paste that I
want to say is equals to this response
from the AI
and then the last thing in here is the
created at so I want to know the date
that the date and time this was sent
so first to do this we need to use
something named time zone so first of
all we need to kind of import time zone
so we get the current time of whoever is
using it so if someone is in America is
the local time zone that's going to be
saved if someone is somewhere in Asia
it's a local time zone that is going to
be saved so we want to do from Django
Dot
dot details
import time zone
so now that we have that we can come
into created at so right here and what
we can just do is to use that time zone
that we imported and then save that so
what we just need to do is to say time
zone
dot now so what this does is that it
gets the current time and saves it as
the created time
so now that that works what we can just
do is to say chat just the way we save
the user by saying user.save we can also
say chat dot save now this should work
successfully let's try this out
so we're going to save this and then
we're going to come in here we're going
to hit refresh and let's also just
refresh this page to see that there's no
chat in here right now but let's say I
say something like Hi how are you doing
and I hit enter
it gives me my response now I want to
come in here I need to refresh and see
boom you can see now now in this chat
table we have a new data that says admin
sent a message saying Hi how are you
doing now if you click on it we should
see details about that we should see
that the user was admin the message user
sent was Hi how are you doing and the
response from the AI was I'm doing well
thank you how about you so now now that
we know that we've been able to submit
this data every single chart into the
database from any user now we could just
show the user the history of their data
that they've been chatting so basically
the history of their messages
now what I want to do is that we want to
show every user the history of their
chat if I refresh this page that chat is
gone even though we still have the data
saved in our database it doesn't show
the user the history so we want to do
that right now now for us to do this is
also very easy and straightforward what
we just need to do is to come here and
before getting the post what we're going
to do is to try and get all the chats of
that specific user so we're going to
have a new variable name chats I'm going
to take from the chat model and we're
going to say that objects
dot filter
you want to say get all the chats from
the user
of the currently logged in user so let
me explain what that does so what it
does is that it returns
so we're just going to say user equals
that so what we just want to what this
does is that it returns all the chats in
our database right here
everything that we have here but it
filters it so it only Returns the one
that has a user so that has the value of
the user as the currently logged in user
so right now we have admin logged in
what it's going to do is that it's only
going to return the chat of admin that's
what that does right there and then
we've saved it in this variable name
chat now what we want to do is to pass
it to leave your space to make it look
clean so we want to pass it in here
you could just say chats
and then we could give it chats so now
our HTML year in our chatbot has access
to all the chat history of this logged
in user so now what we just need to do
is to Now look for a good way to
Showcase it to the user or showcase all
the history to the user now what we're
just going to do in this case is that in
this URL right here so first of all
let's just comment this out I'm gonna
come back to that so let's see if
everything is blank cool so now what we
just want to do is that we want to look
through for all the chats that we send
so remember in our views we sent a
variable name chat and this contains all
the charts of this currently logged in
user so I'm going to Loop through all
those charts it's kind of a list that it
sent to this HTML page and I'm going to
say for chat in chat so once again this
is ginger templating it's like a format
that allows me to use all these
programming terms all this programming
Concepts in a normal HTML file so
initially remember when we use an if
statement in here that now we're using a
for Loop in here so when we have a for
Loop we also need to end that for a loop
so before we do anything let's make sure
we end that for Loop and we say for chat
in chat even though we know that in here
we only got the user that is currently
logged in we also just want to give it
an extra security check right here also
to make sure that if the user that is
currently logged in that we are showing
just to make sure that there's no data
leak or there's no problems in showing
the right message to the right user so
what we're going to do is after saying
the for Loop
if we're going to check that is so we're
going to say if the chat dot user that
means this chart that we sent right if
the user is same as the request the user
the currently logged in user then we
actually want to show that message so
we're gonna do this we're gonna end the
if statement there also
and then what we're just doing is now is
to show the message to the user so we're
going to kind of
do the same thing that we did here so in
here we could actually copy this
and then
all the way to here you just copy
everything to be honest
then we paste that in there but we could
comment it out so we could make it
normal and instead of received we want
this to be sent
so this is the one that we sent and
we'll say
by you
but the difference is that the content
of the message should be chat
which is chat from this chat list so
we're going to say chat
Dutch
message
so now if I come in here let's eat
refresh and see so now it shows me what
I asked the
where I asked the AI before which was I
how are you doing but it doesn't show me
the response that the AI gave me so I
want to have that too
now what I'm just going to do in here
I'm going to copy that again so from
here
I'm just gonna copy that and I'm also
gonna paste that in here I'm gonna
remove the comments by pressing command
slash
and this should be fine right here but
what I want to do instead of chat Dot
message in here I want to uh say chat
the response
so I'm gonna say chat dot response
I'm Gonna Save It come back here and hit
refresh good so now you can see it says
Hi how are you doing and now it says I'm
doing well thank you about you now I
want to say who is Bill Gates
and then it should give me a response of
who Bill gate is it tells me who Bill
gate is and I want to hit refresh as you
can see I hit refresh and it still has
the chat history you know that I I gave
it so I also want to log out if I log
out and let's say I log in back as an
admin
you can see that my chat history is
still intact and everything is working
now what I want to do is to try to be
like another user so I'm going to log in
as told me
you can see now that I have a blank chat
history so since I don't have any chat
history what I can just be nice to say
hey
tell me
tell me about the United
Kingdom
and let's see what it says so should
give us some details about the UK and
let's see it says the United Kingdom is
a sovereign state located of North is
basically it gives us details about the
United Kingdom it refresh I see I have
those data if I log out and let's say I
log in back as an admin
everything
let's make sure we're putting in the
right thing and that is good to tell us
that it shows us when a user doesn't
input valid data so let's login and you
can see it shows me my own data about
what I asked which was how are you doing
and with Bill Gates and if I log in as
tell me it shows me what I asked it
about how the how United Kingdom is so
tell me about United Kingdom now what we
want to do is to use gpt4 in this our
application so as we know gpt4 came out
a while after charging PT was released
and it's much more smarter and
um yeah very much more smarter than the
older gpt3 so I want to be able to use
that GPT for in this application so any
of the user of our application can get
smarter response or better responses so
first use gpt4 we actually need to
change the model that we're using so I'm
going to walk you through the open AI
documentation so right here this is the
open AI documentation and this just
tells us about chat completion so what
we've been using was text completion and
we can also use chat completion so the
major difference is that we have access
to gpt4 and even the
chat completion models are more cheaper
so that those are the main difference so
that's why it's recommended to use this
chat completion I'm going to show you
what you just need to do in the code so
this can basically do anything right you
can draft an email write python code
answer questions about setup documents
do a lot of things this is an actual
chat model so I'm going to show you how
it works so as you can see this is an
introduction
so this is how we call the API we import
open Ai and then instead of saying
openair.completion.create which is what
we've been doing we say open ai.chart
completion.create we give you the model
this is GPT 3.5 and then we tell it we
have to give it like a row in which what
what is meant to do or how it's meant to
be so if I going to go into the
playground in a bit and I'm going to
show you what I mean by a row so as you
can see it says Row the system is we're
telling you that you're an helpful
assistant so basically I can ask you
anything and you should reply me that's
what we're telling the AI and then as
the user the user says who won the World
Cup in 2020
um who are the World Series in 2020 and
then the assistant says the Los Angeles
Dodger won the World Series in 2020 and
then the user says where was it played
and then the AI should continue that
chart and give us a response of when it
was played so that is how that should
work if you see the response of this you
can see the 2020 series was played in
Arlington Texas and it gives us all of
that so this is how this is going to
work and I'm going to show you in detail
how we can implement this but before I
show you the actual code I'm going to
come into this playground and this is
what it is so this is a user and this is
kind of like the chat completion model
and right now I'm on the model gpt4 I
could switch to GPT 3 or GPT for anyone
I want so what I'm just going to do is
to say
um who are you so I could ask you that
and I could say submit
if I say submit you see it says I'm an
AI model created by open air I could I
could even delete this first of all and
just start a conversation and be like
who are you and I can say I am
and human
and I can say oh really
and then let's see what it says
I apologize for my previous response I
Am Not a Human but so you understand
what I'm saying it's kind of completing
from the chat I already created so you
can do various things with this now
let's actually implement this in our
application now for us to do this we're
just gonna have to come in here
now everything we've been doing has been
correct all the models or the chatbots
the URLs login everything is good but we
just need to change now is where we are
accessing or where we are sending a
request to the open AI API so as I said
the only thing we need to change is chat
so where it says chat where it says
opening idle completion we need to write
open ai.chat completion so if we come in
here again in the
documentation you can see that it says
open ai.chat completion that is one of
the major changes and the way in which
you write this is going to be different
we really do not need all of these that
we wrote before
I'm going to show you why so what we
need to do is just to say the model that
we want to use so first of all let's say
we just want to use gpt3
.5 Turbo
and then instead of having all of this
what we're just going to do is to set
messages
and it's going to be like a list so you
see the way
rows you know the first video roll and
we see the way we have a list of like
messed up chats right here that is how
we're gonna do this but for this we just
want to have like two initial chats
or One initial chat actually so let's
just say row so this role is kind of
telling the AI what it is I could tell
you that you are a let's say like a a
tax expert and you're going to help me
with tax or you're like a lawyer and
you're going to help me to write out
some documents you could do anything you
wanted to do so let's just say row
system
and let's say the content of that row
and we can say something like you are an
helpful assistant
good
now we want to have another one and this
one is for the user so we're going to
say
row
user
now this is a message that the user
sends to the AI let's just say content
and the content is the message that the
user sent which is what we pass into
this function I'm going to copy that I'm
going to paste that in here let's just
add a comma to make sure everything is
good now that we have that let's
actually kind of see how this works you
know so what we need to do is to say
print
response
because this is not going to work
because it kind of gives it in a
different response so if I come back
into the documentation and if I come in
here you see that the response format is
different so in choices the actual text
that we want is
choices.message.content but for the
initial one we're using choices
um the first index and then we're using
the text that is not what we want so
let's just comment this out for now and
then let's return
this should actually be response so
let's return response
and don't let us return anything yet
and let's say print response so what I'm
going to do is to
now try this out and I'm gonna say
so let's see if this works so in here
let me show you what I did first I made
sure I printed response so whenever a
user sent a message to this GPT 3.5
table the response that we get I want to
print it in my terminal right here
that's what this does so let's just make
sure and see if that works before we
actually show the user the response so
I'm just going to refresh this page I'll
say I woo for you
and then it should give me a response
right here
so it gave me no from this um because
there is no it's not returning this this
function is not returning anything but
that's not what we're focusing on if we
scroll up we should see the response so
this is the response and it says choices
and we get the first one I'll
consider.message.content so now this is
the content we want we said I it will
you and he said I am an AI language
model designed and in designed to assist
and engage a conversation with users so
that is good let's refresh this you can
see that it didn't save that in the
database which is quite good because
we're not actually returning any
response that's why the database didn't
get anything saved in it so now we know
that this is in choices message so
choices as a list and in that list it
has a dictionary of message and that
message as a dictionary of content so
let's use that now to get the actual
response so what we're going to do is to
just say so now we don't need to print
response no more and then we could
on comments this so we could say
response the choices uh the first one
since it's in a list we say first one
but instead of saying dot text we say
the message
just content
the strip so now this is what we want
and this should be response that was a
typographical error and now we want to
return answer
so now let's see if this works
let's try this we hit refresh now
now we can see who is the
owner of free code Camp let's say the
founder of record camp
let's see what he says
so it says the founder of free code Camp
is Quincy Larson good everything works
successfully and we are using the chat
completion model not the normal text
completion model which is good
so everything works if I hit refresh you
can see that it saves and in here in the
database
so it doesn't allow me to log in because
I'm logged in as Tommy let me change my
login back to admin let me log in as
admin
so now it shows me the message Tommy
said who is the founder of Rico camp and
I can see the response which is good so
now if I come back in here I'm logged in
as admin it changes all the message to
the messages for admin good let me try
and say
when was YouTube
founded
and let's see what it says it says it
was founded in 2005 by the people that
founded it good if I hit refresh
everything works if I come in here that
was saved successfully good now the next
thing I want to do is to actually use
gpt4 in this so as I said gpt4 is more
smarter much more smarter and it gives
more uh it gives better responses so
let's actually Implement gpt4 in this
application that we're building and
let's see the change that we make so the
only thing you need to do to change that
from GPD 3.5 to to 4 is just to remove
this GPD 3.5 and write gpt4 now it
should be using gpt4 let me show you how
I knew that if I come into the
documentation where we have chat
completion so right here you can see the
model is using GP 3.5 but it says it
that you can use GPD 3.5 and you can use
gpt4 so that's why all I know is you
need to change this to gpt4 and if you
come into the playground you can also
see the name of the model gpt4 GTP 3.5
turbo but now we want to use gpt4 so now
let's try this out and let's see
whatever changes we it makes so now we
know that we're using gpt4 and then what
we're just going to do is to come in
here and just say
so that's it refresh and say
something let's tell it to solve a
mathematical equation right so let's say
um what is
actually let's say to write a python
code write a python code
to
check if a number
is a prime number
so let's see what it writes so we're
gonna give you like a second to come up
with the code and for now gpt4 is quite
slower compared to GPD 3.5 and the other
models but we're going to give it a
little bit of time to write that out
because it's much smarter and it's quite
new it's quite slow that's what the open
AI set the people are openly I said and
also if you use chat GPT if you use gpt4
on chargpt it's quite slow for now
so as you can see it writes the code for
us you can use the following python code
to check if a number is prime number so
it tells us the code and the format we
could copy this and
add all the
indentation we're meant to add and it's
probably going to work but as you can
see that is much more smarter it gave us
we wrote python code for us we could
take this to the next level and you know
format all the python code whenever a
code is being written we could format it
to make it look good but for now we
basically done what we want to do right
as you can see it wrote a python
function that checks if a number is
prime and it basically you know explain
everything it did even if it took a
while for gpt4 to do that but it did it
accurately so that is the main thing and
that's the main goal so everything we
wanted to do in this video is done and I
hope you enjoyed this video so that's
going to be all for this tutorial thank
you for watching to the end of this
tutorial and if you enjoyed everything
we did please don't forget to smash the
like button and subscribe and if you
want the full code to everything we did
in this video the link is in the
description below check that out if you
need the full code and once again thank
you for watching and I'll see you in the
next one